present
werd really it's more of a statement
that i want to make and that is about a
proposal that we have put forward and i
hope will be taken forward within the
next couple of months now I what I just
preface it by saying that I can't
imagine that there's a single person in
this room who would not agree that the
destruction of a people's cultural
heritage on the scale that we've
recently seen in Iraq under the
consequent attempt to deprive that
people the legacy of its past and hence
its identity represents an act of
unspeakable inhumanity and yet
fortunately it simply isn't possible to
totally eradicate the ancient past no
matter how severe the attempt something
always remains and it is after all
that's something that those of us who
are archaeologists work with all the
time using the debris of the ancient
abandonments and destructions to
reconstruct civilizations and history
and so it is that whilst we can't do
anything to prevent what's happening in
those parts of Iraq and Syria controlled
by so-called Islamic stage we can at
least prepare for the time when it will
be possible once again to access these
areas and yes as John Curtis has rightly
said huge resources are going to be
needed both in terms of manpower and
money when that time arises we can't
predict whether we're talking about one
year into the future two years five
years even ten years but what I do
believe is we have to do something now
and so what we are going to do at the
British Museum is to create specialized
training program leading to the creation
if you like of a specialized task
horse-based initially at the BM and
subsequently in the field in Iraq this
would be a task force designed or
trained if you like in all the skills of
emergency heritage management
specifically what we're going to do very
soon we hope is to recruit two
archeologists experience archaeologists
who have worked in Iraq for a period of
five years in the first instance they
would Institute a six month training
program at the BM to which for heritage
sector araki professionals at a time
would be invited and we'll work closely
obviously with the Iraqi authorities to
choose the right people the program will
be devoted to museum and site disaster
work construction and manipulation of
databases digitization of objects
documents emergency retrieval strategies
forensic collection and documentation
methodologies extensive multi-purpose
photographic training principles
conservation architectural restoration
techniques of recording and data
representation systems and so on and so
forth an intensive course following the
six-month training period these BM
curators or archaeologists would return
to Iraq with the trainees in order to
set up programs within their museums or
institutions using appropriate computer
and photographic equipment to revive the
documentation of existing collections
and develop strategies to cope with a
very diverse requirements of
archaeological site management a core
element within this second six-month
period will be the detailed instruction
in techniques of rescue archaeology
involving the establishment of joint
training excavations so the effect of
this rolling programme which as I say we
want to start always straight away will
be to create a large and well trained
Corps that can cope with a full range of
archaeological heritage needs when it
becomes possible
and to survey the archaeological
landscape of Iraq in what other parts
become accessible this will mean that
local heritage professionals we fully
qualified to respond to the realities of
recent damage and establish priorities
for action and best practice thank you